first up she is president and CEO of the
polling company and campaign manager for
you-know-who mr. Donald Trump
we thank of her being here Kellyanne
Conway is joining us by satellite hey
[Applause]
Kelli Ann first of all I have to thank
you you have been doing our show for
over 20 years you are one of our
original blonde conservatives along with
Ann Coulter who is still a friend of
mine to the consternation of many but
you did not give up on us now that you
have become Donald Trump's campaign
manager you stuck it out and I thank you
for being here I'm happy to go and I
must say I have mixed emotions first of
all you are enabling pure evil but I'm
like so proud of you I mean you started
here you were just a child star on our
show and and now you're perhaps the most
important person in the world because
you seem to be the only person who's
been able to tame Donald Trump many have
tried but only you were able to pull
that sword out of the stone how did you
do it well I don't say it that way I
think I look I walk in the Trump Tower
every day to the campaign and I'm
quickly reminded that Donald Trump did
very well for himself long before I
arrived I just feel like every leader
needs the right environment the right
players around them for them to be them
and he's out there showcasing his
generosity his I think his great sense
of humor his love of the country and his
people and you know Bill I'm so
verklempt that you what plane were you
the girl from Jersey knows what that
means my look I just want to tell you
one thing that you and I have been
talking for over two decades now which
is a real pleasure and a privilege thank
you for calling me your friend and for
giving me a platform with all those
swing voters in your audience tonight
your honor
no no I mean there are there are okay we
have a much bigger audience than all the
other stupid shows that the other
politicians do I know Donald Trump
because of you is trying to reach those
suburban people that's our audience and
some of them are on the fence and that's
why I heard today Donald Trump
encouraged you to do this show he did I
wanted to tell you that he said to say
hello when he heard I was invited he
said you have to go on that show that is
true he did you know he sued me once he
did how'd that go well as soon as a
judge saw it of course he laughed and
threw it out of the court I gotta tell
you who's not laughing I've been to
these rallies I've been to these fairs
this guy has really created the movement
and people feel like they're part of it
and I want to tell you you and I have
been talking for two decades about the
problem with politicians
this guy is an outsider a disrupter a
changemaker and he's not running for the
reason many people run in politics which
is it's my turn I'm next in line I went
money fame status power he already had
all of that and he and his family are
making tremendous sacrifices just to do
this and when I travel around with him
people don't stop and bill and say I
liked you on the apprentice or I want
your autograph they say we need jobs in
this in this date or please save our
country I know you don't like that but
that's what the people saying we have to
respect people are there watching
tonight well I don't have to respect all
the people
I I don't and I don't know I I don't
have to respect all the people I mean
Hillary was right when she's called a
lot of his supporters deplorable because
a lot of what they believe is the play
[Applause]
what I mean I'm wrong but I'm glad we
saw her true feelings for once she
doesn't really give him by the way she
said deplorable just about 12 hours
after her campaign said she's going to
become more uplifting an aspirational so
the voters can see what's in her heart
amidst all the cacophony and noise and
what has she done ever since she's been
negative negative negative the
Democratic Party I grew up in was always
very uplifting and aspirational they
elevated and elected people like JFK and
Barack Obama and Bill Clinton her
message is anti-trump she doesn't have a
positive message if you were running
against Donald Trump your message would
be anti Trump at least she sticks to the
facts in her anti message Donald Trump
has said Hillary will repeal of the
Second Amendment is that your
understanding of what she has said in
the past he said he what she wants to
release all violent criminals from jail
she wants to release all of them is that
when you've heard her say she wants to
repeal the Second Amendment and release
violent criminals she has actually said
that she doesn't like the Heller
decision which was a Supreme Court
decision that held that individuals have
a private right to bear arms under the
Second Amendment she's pretty hostile to
that she actually has been very critical
of President Obama because she thinks he
hasn't gone far enough on open borders
and he's been he's deported many people
in this country so look Bill you in one
hour show you cover more issues and more
substance and she covers in a month she
doesn't talk about issues when's the
last time she gave a speech on taxes on
the middle class on education on health
care she just doesn't do it all right I
don't have time to go through all of his
lies we only have an hour
[Applause]
but let's just divide it for the moment
between the scary and the false now
let's let's start with the scary sheep
pillory said at the end of her
convention speech you can't trust a guy
who can be baited with the tweet with
nuclear weapons okay just in the last
couple of weeks what he has said is
Iranian sailors have made obscene
gestures at our boats so we should blow
them out of the water and that when the
Chinese didn't provide the proper red
carpet when Obama landed there he would
turn the plane around isn't she right is
he really a man who has the temperament
honestly Kellyanne 20 years of
friendship is she really the person he's
he'd the person to be in the Oval Office
yes and by the way she's innovated he is
occupying series real estate in her head
I mean who's been losing in the polls
who seems very rattled and not very
nimble off of her script these days as
you said in your monologue what the heck
happened you said a little bit
differently but I'll clean it up what
the heck happened I mean she had she had
this in the bag every story was look at
the polls the race is over look at the
polls the race is over so let's do look
at the polls now four or five weeks
later we're winning in some of these
swing states that Mitt Romney lost where
she was way ahead because she thought
she would just it would just be a
complete blowout that she just had to
bite her time sit on her lead wait out
the clock she tried to do that against
Bernie Sanders he won 22 states she
tried to do against Barack Obama in 2008
and he walked her and he wanted and so I
think I actually think we're gonna win
bill you know and you feel it I think
you're getting nervous oh I am getting
nervous but it's not because Trump is
good it's because people are stupid
that's why I'm
[Applause]
tell you why I'm getting nervous and
I'll do it with a Donald Trump quote
from the art of the deal he said I play
to people's fantasies people want to
believe that something is the biggest
and the greatest and the most
spectacular
I call it truthful hyperbole I call it
lying here are some lies I never I don't
know anything about David Duke utter lie
Vladimir Putin and I are best friends he
never met him he got a letter from the
NFL which was prude never happened he
gave money to the veterans when he
didn't I was against the Iraq war when
he plainly it's on tape said he was not
how do you answer to the fact that this
man just says whatever he wants at the
moment in the moment to get whatever
point he wants across regardless of the
facts is that true you're cherry-picking
certain things he said on the Iraq war
the timeline is very clear well hold on
he was on Howard Stern's radio show as a
private citizen and Stern asked him so
hey should we invade Iraq what do you
think and he said well I guess so
Hillary Clinton proudly went down into
the well of the United States Senate
asked her vote in favor of the Iraq war
and by the way she's been a hawk for
many years The Wall Street Journal wrote
about it just this week that she's
always been an interventionist so the
Democrats may not like that I know
you're stuck with a lemon here with 53
days to go and we're surging and I'm
sorry for that because she has never
been somebody who recaptures the
momentum we saw her fall apart in 2008
we saw Bernie Sanders win 22 states and
millions of voters just a couple of
months ago bill we see Gary Johnson and
in fact Jill Stein taking votes away
from her she's just been she's
floundering at 40 to 44 percent the
question is why and the answer is very
simple a majority of Americans think
that she doesn't tell the truth she's
not honest or trustworthy and a majority
don't quite like her where if she does
when she will make history but not
because of her gender only okay but
you're not her elected a president that
the majority of Americans felt was
dishonest and untrustworthy okay but
you're you're hurt Kim I mean you're not
her campaign manager you're Donald
Trump's campaign I'm all for a female
press
but not that one I understand but also I
mean you know in the past you've worked
for people like Newt Gingrich Fred
Thompson Jack Kemp I don't agree with a
lot of what they say but they're all
serious Mike Pence I was trying to keep
that out of it but you know these are
all serious people you don't see a
difference between them and Donald Trump
I mean you have many children I mean are
you okay with what your children gonna
be asking you about supporting a man
enabling a man who did things like make
fun of the handicapped and said John
McCain wasn't a war hero what's that
they've endorsed John McCain and Donald
Trump have endorsed each other in the
way they support each other in the races
this year so but but in its but look I
have no problem saying to my children
that I want the future to be better for
them and I already know what Hillary
Clinton is going to do she says it well
I have to look at her website to know
what for God's sake she doesn't even
talk about the issues and that I don't
like I don't I can't support somebody
lies for a living I'm not going to be
lies for a living you just said you
can't support somebody who lies for a
living when I read a list
way ahead let's search the Democratic
blue wall where's the electoral map wait
it was wait a second she's the one who
has 66% of Americans saying she's not
honest and she's not trustworthy she has
earned that but that's what people
believe that's not what is an actual I
deleted emails they know she doesn't
tell the truth about her health
condition they know that she doesn't
tell the truth away where are the 32,000
deleted emails where the 17,000 I'll let
you go at my last what my last question
if Trump if you guys win look me in the
eye through that camera and tell me you
will not actually be more nervous than
if Hillary won I will not be more
nervous if Hillary won I think no I'm
with them I'm with tens of millions of
people in this country bill who have
joined the Trump movement that have said
you are our last hope because she will
tax and regulate she called Isis are
quote determined enemies in her
convention speech are determined enemies
like we're playing a soccer game against
them they're savage murderers who have
killed 33,000 people them and their
predecessors just in the last 13 years
80 percent in the last three years but I
will tell you this your viewers probably
don't know that you and I share a
birthday January 20th inauguration
decoration my guest Bill Maher will see
you there
please keep me out of Guantanamo Bay
that's all I need
Thank You Kelly and John way I gotta
give it to you you did it
alright let's meet our panel